[Music]
today's question comes from sally in
arkansas sally writes my boyfriend and i
have been together two years and are
talking about marriage he is debt free
he is what they call a trust fund baby
but there's one thing i have an issue
with and i don't know if this is just me
or something i shouldn't worry about
when i asked my boyfriend how much is
owed on his house he said i don't know
dad pays it
his house was a gift through an
inheritance i asked her asked him how
much he set aside for retirement
investments investments and he said
again i don't know my parents handle it
am i overstepping any boundaries i mean
shouldn't he know these things for when
his family passes
he should know these things for when he
like becomes a man i was gonna say he
should know these things when he becomes
a grown-up
and he gets married or before he gets no
like yesterday before he gets married
yeah
i'm assuming he's an adult
chronologically yes so sally two things
i want to address here number one
trust your gut
uh
i don't want you to ever have another
thing that you're worried about that you
don't bring up because you think uh what
if this is just me find out if it's just
me and ask and if people actually love
you in your life and you ask them
they'll answer you honestly and directly
and then y'all can move on with your day
so trust your gut on this and number two
your gut is correct yes man
he should know this stuff answers like
uh i don't know dad just does it it's
not a good answer i want my daughter
marrying into that world
yeah ask yourself if you had a daughter
that you valued more than life itself
she was your sweet little princess
would you tell him her to marry this
joker
no
not because he's got wealth not because
his family has wealth
not because he has some money that has
come to him through inheritance but
because he doesn't know anything or do
anything right he's useless
he needs to get i'm sorry was that a
little blunt
so here's what i would do sally i would
say i would
before that
i would say
okay so start the car in the driveway
put the keys in start the car and then
go in and sit down with him and say
the fact that you don't know how much
money you have or how much your house is
worth or your it scares me
and i will not be scared going into my
marriage
i want you to be a grown up i want you
to act like an adult and if we're going
to go into this thing i need to know
where the money is i know how much we
owe what we owe on how we make money how
we don't make money where the
investments are i want to know these
things because i'm a part of this thing
moving forward
there's dignity
in producing
value in the marketplace you do not meet
people who are happy people
who do nothing do nothing they don't
exist they they sit on their butt on the
back of a yacht and do nothing these are
not happy people and if you sounds
romantic it sounds like a bad reality
show it sounds like a movie it sounds
like the end of a movie when somebody
got rich or they robbed a bank or they
did whatever
but
the truth is
serving
others working
helping people giving yourself
fulfillment in that process is what
mature adults do to find happiness this
guy has never enjoyed that proposition
right and you talk about dave like the
doing nothing you can flip that and i
know a lot of people that work really
hard and don't make a ton of money and
they're the most joyful they've got
purpose they bring joy to the to the
people that they work for they've got
purpose in their life they create things
they're builders they're whatever
gotta go do something this is this puts
you in such a position that all you do
is naval gaze it's just so much
introspection going on because he can't
do nothing else he doesn't do anything
else so it really it's just i don't
think you fix this one i think this
one's broken this is a run but if you
want to try you can do john's routine
i'm good with that you sit down and go
this was broken well i mean he's not
permanently broken but i don't want my
daughter marrying a project no i'm not
especially not a project with this kind
of money yeah it's it's a well-funded
dysfunctional project that's right
because here's the other problem
it ain't just him he's married mom and
dad too yeah well these two characters
that are called his parents
suck as parents they don't have any
evidence
and you're marrying into that too and
and i'll guarantee you one of the two of
them is a control freak nut bag
crazy person
i'll guarantee you
don't you think i mean
who else does this to their children
people who get
their own satisfaction out of managing
grown-ups lives controlling i got it
i'll just take care of it yeah
man i'm telling you that's in there i
know nothing about psychology but i'm
old and i've seen a lot